jetzt hat sich donald trump das erste
mal geäußert insofern als dass er die
niederlage eingestanden hat aber wie
viel sorgen macht ihnen das dass dieser
mann immer noch den atom koffer besitzt
es macht mir große sorgen nicht nur was
den atom koffer anbelangt sondern der
zustand des landes der ganz erheblich
durch donald trump so herbeigeführt
worden ist die spaltung ist tiefer
geworden er hat seinen wert liegt über
seine gesamte amtszeit jetzt selber
gesprochen er ist der brandstifter
präsident und er hat den mob
aufgestachelt das herz der
amerikanischen demokratie das capitol
das parlament zu stürmen wenn es einen
grund für ein amtsenthebungsverfahren
jemals gegeben hat hat es gegeben aber
wenn es einen klassischen grund gibt
dann hat donald trump ihn geliefert
er hat er ist verantwortlich für den
angriff auf die amerikanische demokratie
es ist aber eine verfassungsrechtliche
frage ob man und wie man innerhalb von
wenigen tagen ist er jetzt noch zwölf
tage im amt das erledigen kann
da gibt es zwei unterschiedliche wege
für den einen weg braucht man auch die
eigene regierung und ob die regierung
dazu bereit ist ist sehr offen ich
glaube es eher nicht darum glaube ich
dass es dieses amtsenthebungsverfahren
auf die schnelle jetzt nicht mehr gibt
dass meine einschätzung von der
situation in den usa gehen sie davon aus
dass es ermittlungen auch gegen donald
trump geben wird die eine frage ist ob
es ermittlungen gibt die aus früherer
zeit rühren auch aus seiner amtszeit
herrühren
das kann ich das kann gut sein das weiß
ich nicht ich glaube dass auch sein
letzter akt diese brandstiftung dieses
aufrühren das aufstacheln und anstiften
auch eine strafrechtliche untersuchung
verdient mit welchem ergebnis das ist
die aufgabe dann von unabhängigen justiz
behörden aber ich finde dass es hier
strafrechtliche anknüpfungspunkte gibt
und könnte mir gut vorstellen dass es
auch zu strafrechtlichen untersuchungen
kommt aus früherer zeit aber auch aus
genau diesem verhalten jetzt rund um die
us wahl hat es sehr unterschiedliche
aussagen über donald trump gegeben
was passieren könnte wie man mit den
umgehen sollte ich möchte ihnen einmal
zeigen was ihr konkurrent um den
parteivorsitz friedrich merz damals im
oval office über donald trump und eine
mögliche arbeitsbeziehung zu ihm gesagt
hat wie gut könnte ein bundeskanzler
friedrich merz mit einem us präsidenten
donald trump zusammenarbeiten
ich habe viel erfahrung im umgang mit
amerikanischen gesprächspartnern
amerikanischen politikern ich bin nun
beruflich auch sehr viel in amerika
gewesen ich weiß wie die amerikaner
ticken wir kämen schon klar aber aus
einer position des selbstbewusstseins
heraus und einer position der stärke und
in einer position der schwäche
wir kommen schon klar hat friedrich merz
gesagt tim sie auch klar mit donald
trump ich habe auch viel kontakt und
viel erfahrung mit amerikanischen
gesprächspartnern mit kollegen mit
freunden mit diplomat mit journalisten
aber ich habe diesen satz nicht gesagt
und hätte ihn auch nicht gesagt und auch
schon gar nicht zu einem zeitpunkt in
dem donald trump schon angefangen hatte
den zu versuchen die wahl und das
auszählen zu beeinflussen die auszählung
zu unterbinden und darum wäre ich mit
ihm als präsident wenn er wiedergewählt
gewählt worden wäre als ein möglicher
bundeskanzler so wenig klar gekommen wie
die amtierende bundeskanzlerin oder auch
andere europäische regierungschefs mit
ihm klar gekommen wären
er hält sich nämlich nicht an die regeln
der demokratie
und er war nicht freundschaftlich
gesonnen uns und darum hätte ich den
satz nie gesprochen
jemand der nicht mitbewerber ist
zumindest im direkten umfeld ist jens
spahn der im team mit armin laschet
antritt jetzt gibt es berichte bei uns
bei bild aber auch im spiegel dass er
dennoch sondiert ob er kanzlerkandidat
werden kann in der cdu hat mit mehreren
spitzenpolitikern telefoniert hat jens
spahn das zeug kanzlerkandidat zu werden
die frage stellt sich nun wirklich nicht
und ich glaube es haben jetzt auch alle
etwas anderes zu tun
die nicht in der regierung sind ich
glaube auch vor allen dingen die in der
regierung sind ich glaube auch vor allen
dingen die die mit der pandemie jetzt in
deren bekämpfung vordringlich sich
beschäftigen und ich glaube es gibt
jetzt für alle andere prioritäten in der
partei aber vor allen dingen auch in der
regierung in der regierung heißt die
priorität pandemie bekämpfung und nicht
was anderes wenn jetzt heute noch mal
300 millionen impfdosen von der
europäischen union geordert wurden
sozusagen nachgestellt wurden muss man
dann jetzt auch mal klipp und klar sagen
dass am anfang zu wenig gekauft wurden
weil das ist ja das was ansparen
bestreitet er hat in den vergangenen
wochen immer wieder gesagt nein es gibt
genug jetzt gibt es heute die nachricht
der 100 millionen mehr muss man mal klar
sagen am anfang es gab zu wenig es gibt
zu wenig das kann sein dass man das zu
einem späteren zeitpunkt alles klären
muss aufarbeiten muss
ich bleibe bei dem was ich eben in einem
anderen zusammenhang gesagt habe ich
finde es gibt jetzt eine priorität ein
gebot das heißt handel das heißt diese
pandemie alles zu tun um die pandemie
unter kontrolle zu bekommen
das ist jetzt das gebot der stunde
keiner möchte jetzt dass es auch noch
nebenbeschäftigungen gibt keiner möchte
jetzt dass es streit gibt auch der
vizekanzler der in alles eingebunden ist
als vizekanzler von der kanzlerin als
bundesfinanzminister und als ein
schlaumeier der eigentlich immer doch
alles weiß der weiß auf einmal gar
nichts das versteht auch keiner wir
wollen jetzt handelnde kompetente
politiker und nicht besserwisser oder
nicht wissen wir sind bild und wir
liefern dir deine news auf youtube zum
nächsten video kommst du hier und
vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren